bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous on vient de le voir plus de 300
soignants se sont envolés hier pour donc
soulager les hôpitaux antilles et
comment est ce que vous accueillez
l'arrivée de ces nouveaux renforts
bonjour
ça va nous les accueillons évidemment
avec pour nous c'est un grand soutien
seulement nous aimerions que les choses
soient beaucoup plus régulière dans la
mesure où ça fait des années que nous
nous exigions qu'il y ait des moyens et
parce que nous savions qu'à tout moment
toto un jour on way ce genre de problème
effectivement il faut qu'il y ait ce
genre de crise mais il n'ya pas que ce
genre de crise je rappelle que nous
sommes sur un territoire qui qui a qui
fait face à plusieurs types de risques
lorsque ses collègues parce qu'on cette
crise avec nous ils repartiront
dans l'hexagone nous aurons à faire face
à d'autres types de crises notamment au
niveau des risques naturels et ma foi
ça reste conjoncturel j'en ai déjà dit
je le répète ça s'est passé et alors que
le problème est structurel
ce qui inquiète en tout cas pour
l'instant
la guadeloupe c c'est la pandémie
comment évolue la situation à l'heure
actuelle est ce que le nombre de
patients augmente de jour en jour on
sait qu' il y a eu de nombreux morts
déjà la semaine dernière des dizaines
chaque jour
oui la situation est très
très difficile il ya effectivement un
certain nombre de personnes décédées on
ne met pas heureusement que de la
colline
mais effectivement le directeur fait des
ravages ceci étant dit
c'était prévisible pourquoi c'était
prévisible parce qu'en fait nous étions
ouverts jusqu'à la mi juin et il y à il
ya eu
5 6 peut-être même 7,8 porter par jour
et malheureusement la circulation du
virus a eu lieu à ce moment là il m'a
froissé sinon en tout cas c'est notre
analyse
il nous semble que c'est l'origine même
du mal l'origine du mal elle n'est pas
autochtones contrairement à ce que dit
l'aiac est
là le gouvernement
qu'est ce que vous voulez dire par là
pas autochtones que ça aurait été
transmis via des des voyageurs oui c'est
ado qu'il ya un nom il ya eu à un moment
donné où la rs
a estimé que c'était le comportement des
citoyens locaux or c'est la circulation
parce que sept à huit heures par jour ça
c'est conséquent la population a triplé
à un moment donné
ça reste donc pour nous à notre analyse
c'est celle à l'origine de la
circulation du virus ce que j'aurais eu
que c'est delta qui vient de l'extérieur
et le scénario qui vient de l'extérieur
oui bien sûr après ce qu'on sait aussi
c'est que la vaccination avance très
lentement également est ce que vous
pensez qu'il ya une prise de conscience
parmi parmi les citoyens pour aller se
faire vacciner
mettre un terme en tout cas ralentir la
propagation du virus sur le territoire
puisqu'il fait des ravages on le
rappelle aux antilles
alors sur la question de la vaccination
il ay ay si une méfiance par rapport non
pas la vaccination
les gens ne sont pas anti vaccination va
me dire pratiquement tout le monde est
vacciné contre auxerre d'autres maladies
c'est précisément sur le produit qui est
présentée et nous avons un passé où on
nous a jamais dire presque empoisonné
avec notamment le
laplaud de l'école et ça reste encore
dans l'esprit des gens je veux le dire
clairement
donc ce produit qu'on nous présente
aujourd'hui comme étant un vaccin ici
qu'il autres cadres de la majorité au
reste des gens qui restent de quatre
très méfiante jusqu'à jusqu'à ce jour il
ya quand même un regain on est y est on
était là il ya deux semaines avec 20 %
peut-être qu'on a de quoi 25% mais ça ne
bouge pas beaucoup malgré le fait que le
delta effectivement fasse des dégâts les
gens restent très méfiants ils
continuent à prendre leurs précautions
et même à être que comme j'ai vu dans
votre cas votre sujet tout à l'heure
qu'il ya des manifestations dans
l'hexagone ici aussi demain matin il y
aura une manifestation chaque samedi
aussi il ya encore des manifestations
parce que on remet en question la
gestion de du gouvernement on remet en
question parce que pourquoi nous
estimons que si les hôpitaux sont
saturés ce n'est pas parce que les gens
ne sont pas
vacciner c'est simplement parce que
renvoie les gens chez eux avec un
doliprane alors qu' il y à d'autres
possibilités de prise en charge le
traitement des converse et il ya même
jeu soupèse mémoire il y a même une
espèce de blocus sur un certain nombre
de traitements ils les gens sont très
remontés ils le savent les gens sont
très remontés très en colère contre ces
sept comme on dirige cette gestion de
qualité qui ne qui ne correspond pas du
tout à ce qu'il devait faire merci
beaucoup aux philippe bélair pour toutes
ces précisions je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire général de la cgtg santé
guadeloupe merci à vous